my name is max flour and I am an
engineer
sometimes engineers slash data
scientists at Foursquare and I work on
our recommendation engine and I do a lot
of work on our natural language
processing stack which I give a lot of
talks about that sometimes various
meetups and I also like to look at some
more you know kind of theoretical issues
in Bayesian statistics and machine
learning in my spare time which is kind
of more what I'm talking about today but
I like to bring it into my work
sometimes so we'll talk about that as
well so yeah that's mostly about me
this clock does have a dedication I know
that's a little bit unusual but my
remarks is my grandfather and
unfortunately he passed away last week
and I used to talk to him about this
stuff sometimes and I know that he would
be here
if if he could so let's get started ok
this my friends is the display
distribution everyone get it all right
good I can go now
No all right this is I mean some of you
are like oh yeah this makes sense I know
so just just I'm just curious Lee's
gonna show of hands how many of you
already know what this is and what this
represents is it clean all right so I
think about like we've got a quarter of
you that's there so believe it or not if
you want to teach someone about the
Dirac wave distributions pretty clear if
you just throw this up on the screen
it's not really going to do much for you
you might understand all the symbols in
that equation
like parse what it's doing but I don't
really like to learn things like that so
kind of understands I understand what
the heck is actually going on so this
talk is going to be more focused on
building intuition as to what this
distribution is why it's important in
statistics and why we could use it in
Bayesian statistics and machine learning
so let's start with something a little
simpler how about something that
everyone here I think could understand a
pie chart everybody a part in this case
we've got you know six five different
possible values and there's different
percentages on each I think we all all
can like all can impart this so this is
also known as a discrete distribution or
a multinomial distribution it just means
that hey there are five different
categories we're uncertain which
category is going to be selected and
here are the here's the breakdown here's
the percentages that we can do this so
we're gonna introduce K you notice that
fact back here there was okay we're
going to introduce K as a number of
possible categories in this case K is 5
so let's look at some examples for a
multinomial distributions and these are
some that I look at like every single
day at work so this one is the
distribution of positive and negative
signals or positive negative reviews on
Foursquare for different Foursquare
venues if you look at a you know a venue
like Heat you're at a is - there's likes
and dislikes if you look at a place like
McNally Jackson bookstore it's gonna
have a very different distribution than
the 14th Street post office everybody
takes another one now here here we have
a little more complicated because K is
168 the week is broken up into 168
different hours and you know goes from
week hour 0 which is Monday morning from
12 a.m. to 1 a.m.
all the way to week hour 167
and so what this means is this is just
the distribution of people going there
throughout the week the highest one
which is like Friday afternoon you could
see it goes to about three and a half
percent that means that three and a half
percent of people who go to the museum
of murder I know at that time you know
you can see Tuesday's lower because it
used to be closed on Tuesday before we
had a pie chart why isn't this a pie
chart I'll give you a pie chart here you
go okay so for hamburgers so okay what
does the raw data look like we don't get
pie charts in the raw data we don't get
multinomial distributions in the raw
data we only get counts so when we look
at our database usually this is produced
it's an aggregate we just got it counts
and then the number of columns are
represent the number of different values
so there are K columns of data in our
County first column is just the ID and
then there n rows of data so there could
be lots and lots of different rows and
the problem with that or a problem or
things I should point out is that the
counts and the multinomial distribution
are not the same
but you can calculate one for the other
so you could estimate the multinomial
from the count so in this case we've got
three categories and this is like you
know I'm thinking cars stop the traffic
light I'm gonna hit the green light I'm
gonna get the yellow light on the other
day the red light and you've got you've
got these these three digit numbers in
there in that first row so we can
calculate for that traffic light you
know what percentage of people hit that
each color so we'll sum up we'll get to
750 and then divide pretty simple
awesome we get some percentages very
easy okay so there's no problem until we
start something like this here we have
one this traffic light they don't really
have a whole lot of data for this
traffic light so we're going to get 25%
50% and 25% now you're starting to
wonder this is really not as accurate as
it was before is it and this one we only
have one piece of data and it's yellow
does that mean we're willing to say that
100% of this people who hit this traffic
light or are yellow this is the all
under percent of the time I would think
that's a it's it's a crazy inference to
make and now now we're just dividing by
zero we have no data and you know if
you're not careful you're gonna throw an
exception so Bayesian statistics for the
rescue to sort of model what's going on
here
and you know it took to put into
mathematics that we kind of know
intuitively is going on here um we're
still going to assume that each row was
generated by a multinomial distribution
but we just don't know which one could
be anymore
and what we're going to do is we're
going to model this with a deer explain
distribution that's what it is it's a
probability distribution over all
possible multinomial distributions all
possible pie charts that you can get so
it represents our uncertainty over what
the actual distribution is that created
the data in that row ok so now we're
gonna look at the equation again we're
not going to do more with it but we're
going to look at what us some more of
these values represent so P represents
the probability or the multinomial
distribution alpha is the parameters of
their choice of each garishly
distribution is parametrized by K okay
dimensional vector alpha and then K so
the number of categories so you want to
know what the probability is of P the
multinomial distribution given alpha
given the darish lease and then we're
going to want to update it so what does
that mean well each row starts off with
a deer Schley to represent our
uncertainty over the multinomial and
then as more data comes in for that row
we can update that that darish later we
can update what we think the multinomial
is going to it is for that row and it
gets more and more precise as we collect
more data
unfortunately if you do the if you apply
Bayes rule and use the math and you take
the Dirac slain distribution and you
update it with data the output you do
all the math I recommend you do it it's
actually it's kind of fun when it
actually all works out is that the
result is another darish length
distribution with different outfits so
that means that you could stay in darish
Leyland's the whole time you don't have
to leave this this one form of
distribution so that's why it's also
known there's a conjugate prior and yet
and guess what it's there's something
even better about if these are your
three alphas you have one alpha for
green one alpha for yellow one alpha to
red if you apply another data point to
that row say a yellow that's equivalent
to just all you have to do is add one to
the yellow column now this is great now
this is a really easy to update so let's
look at why this works let's take a
let's take a closer look to see why that
to get a handle on why that works and
we're going to introduce a concept
called entropy which you might be aware
another name for entropy it has a lot of
different names it's also called
information or information content
sometimes it's known as energy in
machine learning and I a lot of times
they're trying to minimize energy
function and often times energy is
represented as the entropy of a specific
value it's also known as the
log-likelihood or minus the log of the
the probability so let's look at some
actual values here of a venture so an
event that's certainly that you're
absolutely certain is going to happen
contains when it happens it contains no
information - so it has zero entropy
when a coin flips and the coin lands on
tails then that's one bit of information
and it's a you know you could see that
kind of spikes a little bit when a pair
of dice you roll them and lands on six
that's a little higher if the dice if it
lands on 12 let's even higher entropy
because there's only one
there's only one configuration of the
dice that was possible to land on 12
where there's multiple ones as possible
in about six I pulled out some more data
from our Foursquare corpus for any given
word to be the word delicious
is that high event for any word to the
cronut is much higher because the creek
can only get cronuts at certain places
and the winning numbers for the
Powerball lottery is the highest one on
this chart so okay let's look at this
again and let's look at it in terms of
entry now I want to point out this whole
block is just a normalizing constant all
it does is make sure that the
probability distribution adds up to 100
all the numbers have to add up to 1 and
it uses the gamma function it's like the
factorial function the most often given
definition of the gamma function is
basically integral so it's almost
defined by definition to be used to be a
normalizing constant for these types of
distributions so this is just a constant
term and we can ignore it if we don't
really care if you want to just get the
ratio of the probability of different
events we don't really want to normalize
the whole thing so we can not take a
look at that so let's look at the the
entropy or the or create an energy
function for this probability by taking
minus the log all right so that's what
it looks like now and as we as you might
be aware the log of product is the sum
of the logs so we'll put that in there
and then you notice the last term is
minus the log of P sub K and
okay is the probability you know is the
slice of the pie chart for for category
K and that is just going to be the
information content or the entropy of
that particular value of the multinomial
so we'll put that in there and now this
equation up top looks pretty simple it's
just linear in the energy of the site
the entropy of the dirt weight
distribution is linear in the entropy of
the individual components of the
multinomial distribution and information
content is added it so if you get more
points if you get more data points you
can even add that information content
and that kind of explains why why it has
such a beautiful you know update update
update function so so let's let's watch
this one update there prior right now is
1.2 3.0 and 0.3 we start off with a
prior distribution we haven't seen any
data yet we just have to assume
something we get a green point it comes
in we update you got a red one update
that you get another red one update that
piece of cake all right so we have this
parse what this really means when I see
one three two how do I think in my mind
what this distribution is going to be
looking like well let's divide it into
two components on the left side we're
going to normalize it so we're going to
make sure we're going to divide it all
by six so so all of them sum to one and
then we're going to keep that sum on the
right side so the left side represents
the expected value of the distribution
so that you can think of hey that's
that's the multinomial that we think is
is expected for for that row in this
particular case and then on the right
side we have some kind of a weight and
we're not sure what it means yet but in
order to understand what it means I'm
going to draw an analogy to normal
distribution because most people
understand the normal distribution if
you talk to most people at your company
or you're trying to explain something
nominal distribution is usually a good
place to start because everybody kind of
has a baseline intuition for what that
is so a normal distribution has a mean
and a standard deviation we already
talked about the mean of the stearic leg
so how does the standard deviation fit
in well variance is the standard
deviation squared and precision is going
to be 1 divided by the variance so how
does precision affect what we're talking
about when we talk about normal
distribution well if you have a very
high precision it's the low standard
deviation you're very certain that the
points that are going to be drawn from
that normal distribution are going to be
close to the mean if you have a low
precision that's sort of the you know
that's sort of the graphs that are more
spread out the points that are going to
be drawn are going to be far away from
the mean so the way that I like to think
of it is that this weight value is a lot
like precision in the normal
distribution so let's look this is an
example of a two dimensional darish
light distribution that's also known as
like the beta distribution and we're
gonna watch this video it's gonna start
out with a very high precision and then
it's gonna go down so what's how do i
how do i press play here no
ah here we go okay so now it's going
down okay
and at some point so normal distribution
just kind of spreads out infinitely
whereas this is you know this is a beta
distribution so it's you know it's
between 1 & 0 0 & 1 and you know at some
point it has nowhere else to spread out
so it just kind of lines the walls so
let's think about what that means here
no I can't go forward if I just click
yeah there we go
so this is a high weight distribution
here we have 40% blue 40% red 20% yellow
I think it shows an arm just orangish
yellow so that's the mean and if you
have a very high weight then in every
example you're going to be very close to
the mean which means you're going to get
that same mix of points if you have a
very low weight distribution then you're
going to be close you're gonna be far
away from the mean and as far away from
the mean as possible means you're at one
of the corners of the simplex in other
words one yeah you're gonna have a pie
chart with one color dominating the
whole thing but different colors might
be selected at different times so notice
the difference between these two you've
got the same proportions of colors
between the two of them you know the
same dots they're just organized a lot
differently each pull out of the area so
another way to think of a Darrel a
distribution is an urn mod so this is an
urn you know with three colors yellow
and blue or yellow red and blue and
changed up a little bit each slide I
don't know why so you could think of
this as a being one one one and then the
rules are every time you pick a random
color out of the urn you put it back in
but then you put another one in of the
same color so it might look like this
they pulled out red and put it another
red now look in the second on the next
draw you're going to be much more likely
to pull out red okay and so you get this
kind of rich get richer effect whereas
if you already have a lot in the urn
you're gonna get a lot more so you might
get yellow but it's too late because red
is already it's already winning now if
your if your urn already has a lot of
data in it then it's going to be very
hard to change the distribution over
time it's basically you know if you have
thousands of points in there
you've essentially converged it's not
going to change very much over time so
what you could think of happening is
that darish late distribution it starts
off with an urn and the configuration of
whatever the Alpha parameters are and
then you let that urn play out to the
limit and then whatever that limit is
that's the pull out of the that that's
the multinomial you pull down so yeah so
that just says that okay and then I
should point out the Chinese restaurant
process which is kind of like the or
theorist late process which is an
infinite version of the darish leg can
also be thought of like this in this
case you've got these white data points
and whenever you pull out a light data
point you put it back but then you pick
a new color that you've never seen
before and put it back in
so stuff like this might happen and what
happens here is that this this thing
could be used to model something where
you have an infinite number of
possibilities or very large number of
possibilities maybe like words that
people are using in a certain language
and the number of white data points that
you start with is going to represent how
you know how divided the data how
divided the pool is so if you start with
a very low number of white data points
then you're gonna have one color
dominating you're like one word
dominating the entire dominating the
entire data set if you have a large
number of white ball then you're gonna
have lots of different colors and it's
gonna be all mixed ok so let's go back
to the tabular data that we see a lot
over and over again so we have we we
want each way to represent a multinomial
and we want to give each row a prior
during this turbulent and so we have to
ask ourselves which prior Derrick weight
distribution explains the data that we
see and what we can do is we could use
Newton's method to find the most likely
Duraflame distribution that explains
that data now current implementations of
Newton's method well all implementations
of Newton's method require computing the
gradient and the Hessian the first
derivative and the second derivative of
that data but usually that requires
looping through the entire dataset on
each pass Newton's method that could
take a long time so what I've done in
this I guess will send this out
but what I've done in a kind of a just I
wrote a python script it's open you call
get it is that it makes a
pre-computation
on the data it compresses it in in an
intelligent way so that you don't have
to run through all the data every time
you want to find the the the D relay
that works so let's look at how this
works it's it's it's better to look at
in terms of a an illustration and it
works very it works most well when you
have lots of sparsely populated rows and
this is very true in something like for
Foursquare venues where we've got lots
of venues lots and lots and lots of them
we don't want to you know we don't want
to loop through them a lot but each
venue doesn't have a whole lot of
reviews associated with it you know 100
200 some have like 6 and you want to
make use of that too yeah
Oh what's the dataset okay so the
question is what are these rows
represent so um let's say I mean I was
using a traffic analogy before so if
we're gonna extend that analogy then
each row represents a different traffic
light and then each and then each data
represents a an observation of what
happens when people stop at that time
hit that traffic light so if you have
the two column data set like we use it
at Foursquare for likes and dislikes it
would be two columns each each row
represents a different venue and then
you know the first column would be
number of people who left positive
signal and then the next column would be
number of people who left a negative
scene so moving on what does this
compression look like so I can press it
into all the data into this matrix and
the number of columns and the matrix is
I'm calling it m and that's gonna be the
number of the maximum number of data
points at each row so usually it's more
than six but hopefully it's not that
huge but yeah that row could go on and
on and on and the number of columns well
there are three columns for K and then
the bottom column represents the totals
so how does this work so all right so K
is 3 and M is 6 in this case we read in
one row and we see that this row has one
green zero of everything else and it
counts one in the green row and one in
the total row now we see this one has 1
green 3 and yellow and 2 in red and the
way it counts it is that it puts in a
maximum of one per cell and then it
counts forward so for example when that
goes in so it goes in like this the
Green has 1 so it's going to add one's
the first column the yellow has 3 so
it's going to add to the first three
columns and
the red is two so it's going to add to
the first two columns the total is six
so it's gonna add everything on the
bottom and here's another one you're all
six in yellow here's another one here's
therefore total so as it turns out if
you loop through all your data and you
calculate this matrix using just this
matrix you can calculate the optimal
darish lay without having to run through
the data again so that's I'm working on
an academic paper that that explains
this in more detail and the code that I
have up does it will do a demo of that
code I think right now so why don't I
disconnect for just a second so I can
get my demo up
okay yeah
oh that's a good questions the question
was do we make the assumption that each
traffic light comes from the same dear
Ashley distribution so it's different
multinomial but same directly and the
answer is yes that's the assumption of
this model so that's the simplest
version it's not gonna it's not the most
expressive model possible but you can
imagine extending that and we'll talk
about that in a minute by doing a
mixture model or something okay oh I
better I better make this bigger
okay how's discovery but see that all
right I think you're pretty good okay
good
let me just look at what I've got going
on here so I've got a sampling tool so I
can sample from a directional a
distribution sorry I'm kind of trying to
let's actually go a little smaller just
so that I can that's not all right I
better turn around or something okay
I think I got it so I can sample from a
Duraflame multinomial let me just give
my self help said I know what I need so
n is the number that we want to sample M
is the number of samples per row and a
represents the Alpha so let's do that
let's let's generate ten rows each row
let's do 20 data points per each row and
let's do let's look at a darish lay of
1/2 once what's it saying here oh I
still have help
there we go and there is our 20 rows now
let's look at a dearest lay that's got a
much lower weight so maybe I'll do point
one point two and point one you see how
the data is much less mixed up there's a
lot of zeros there are a few were like
20 or 18 or all most of them are all one
category let's do one that's a lot
higher let's do
it's a second okay
let's try 10 2010 now we can see that
they're all ruffians
okay the next thing that I want to do
after this is there's another
possibility where you could do a - Oh
which kind of puts it in that form that
I was talking about before
oh how do we alas is Europe oh maybe
it's just true no I'm sorry
Oh a is the is output so that's the that
that's the dirty parameters let's
actually look at health Oh count matrix
that we want okay
No oh you matrix okay
there we go so that's just the matrix
that I was computing before we could do
it automatically
okay so let's go back to this and the
idea is we have this data how can we
reconstruct what the most likely
directly is from that data and so we
have the tool that does that as well and
that's find directly prior
actually it'll probably tell me oh there
we go I think I need to give it a Kay
hang on a sec
yeah so I need to give it the number of
categories
so in this case we have three categories
and we're gonna turn verbose off there
we go so just given this small data set
you know it converges to one point two
two point five one point two which is
close to what we said but because we
didn't have a whole lot of data we
couldn't really do it let's say we give
it more data we make in you know a
thousand we're looking at a thousand
rows here which isn't even that much see
it gets much closer 1.0 1.9 1.0 and
notice it could even deal with lower m
values so even if you only have say
three values for each row it still is
not as close but it still gets pretty
close and notice how fast it is it
basically takes that you know it build
that matrix and once once you have that
matrix that's right that's what I worked
on yeah
if if each Rome has one data point Wow
so okay
so your question is what happens if each
row only has one data point so if what's
that well so so this there's a problem
here because if each row if all of your
rows have only one data point then it's
impossible to find the weight of the
Dirac leg because you have no idea how
mixed up it is we're not right because
remember there were there was the
circles that were mixed up and then the
circles that were where like each point
was the same color if you're just
drawing one value from each circle you
have no idea sting guaa SHhhh one from
the other but if you have rows with one
data point in it mixed with other rows
with more data points than you can use
that you can use that to make a better
prediction yeah
how do you choose alpha well so that's
what this this script does it chooses
alpha for you so I'm giving it kind of
fake data over here where I chose alpha
and I generated the data but usually
what I'll do is I'll feed in my own data
set
you know from foursquare data or
whatever I'm working on and then this
finds garishly Pryor script will will
give me the alphas so that's exactly
what it does yeah yeah oh right so the
way Newton's method works is how many
you are familiar with Newton's method
okay so like about half a fee okay so it
uses the first derivative and the second
derivative it basically says it picks a
random value of alpha and some values
are going to be more likely than others
and it's trying to climb the hill it's
trying to find the most likely value and
it'll say okay it'll find the prior you
know which direction should I be it'll
do gradient ascent you know which
direction should I be going in and then
it uses the Hessian the second
derivative to figure out okay what's the
learning rate how fast should I be going
in that direction and then ultimately it
converges on the optimal point so you
could start it anywhere no matter where
you started it always converges in the
same point because you know this is a
it's a convex
it's a convex dataset and it only has
one maximum yes
nope but that's a good question that's
that's something that I'm trying to
argue is like something that we should
look into because I think it could but
you know oh so the the three parameters
are the Alpha are the alphas that
represent the distribution so darish
weight distribution you know we saw
before that it's it's it's parameterised
by alpha so if you just give the Alpha
that it represents the whole
distribution so all right let me let me
go back to my slides and after I'm
plugging this for a second just to see
what I'm doing
then we could go back into this
questions just a few more
sometimes when you plug this back in it
kind of links a lot okay that was the
demo okay so this is just an example of
a while back I said in all the data on
Foursquare of venue popularity by week
our because we were we had made the
assumption beforehand that a venue would
be equally popular any time of the week
like doesn't matter 4 a.m. 4 p.m.
equally popular and said well we should
make some assumption about the venue
that's not that when it first starts out
and so we put all the data into this
algorithm and this is what it spit out
this is the 168 dimensional prior and so
you could see even before collecting
data about a venue we're going to be
assuming that it's a lot more popular at
4 a.m. then at 4 p.m. and this is good
because then you know otherwise new
venues we're gonna look at old venues
and we're gonna say well this is an old
venue it's not gonna be very popular for
him and then we're gonna look at a new
venue and we're saying well we have any
data for it's ok flat and then 4 a.m.
all of a sudden looks a lot better but
that's not true yeah
so what this does is it kind of puts the
old done using the new venues on a equal
playing field okay so now I just want to
kind of you mention this a little bit
sort of expand how could we use this how
can we expand beyond just this plain old
you know dear Schlabach
so I kind of gave an analogy between
darish lays and normal distributions
gaussians so it seems to me that
anything that you would want to do with
Gow scenes you can also do with their
slaves you could do it in the same way
so if you want to use the e/m algorithm
to find the mixture of gaussians using a
data set you know you can use the EM
algorithm to finds a mixture of darish
latencies and data set I'm sure it's
done all the time
and let's suppose let's make thing you
want to make it a little more
complicated let's say we want to assume
that each row is a mixture of
multinomial that are chosen elsewhere
and that the coefficient of each
multinomial that the coefficients are
themselves multinomial and they are
drawn from a Dirac wave so what is that
it turns out that that's lately there's
a allocation that's equivalent to a
topic model which you know I'm sure has
talked about in its meetup sometimes a
lot of a lot of machine learning talks
and so that's an interesting thing to
think about because you know why would
you want to have a very low weight on
that Dirac lay if you have a very low
weight it means that each document that
you read is going to be dominated by a
single topic and the more topics that
you add to the document the more
penalized that model is going to be so
that's good for for labeling documents
and giving that giving it that low
weight is going to be good for making
sure that those documents get very clear
very clear topic labels for those of you
who so yeah I just want to end with that
obviously it's something to look into
further but yeah it helps to understand
if you if you're looking at if you're
going to talk about Lda or topic models
I feel like I mean you know it's one of
the songs I had gone to a bunch of talks
about that early on you know I was first
getting into machine learning and I
realized it helps to have a good grasp
of what the D relay is I want to
understand those things
I hope this pub help
so that's all I have
there's any more questions okay so the
question is we have a row with zero data
0 0 0 and what distribution do you want
so the answer to that is that you're
gonna want to use the prior so every row
is given a prior that's the darish lay
distribution before you've seen any data
and that's the prior that's going to be
used at that row we have 0 0 0 and what
prior you use is what the script I was
showing calculates but you have to have
lots of rows in order to get a good
prior if you don't have any rows and you
don't know what to do there's not much
you can do you just have to kind of
guess yeah
right yes right right so notice that the
wait a little bit I mean the weight of
this distribution is not that high I
think it was around 30 or something so
30 check-ins 30 pieces of data can
override or can match this data so I
mean you know look at 4 a.m. is around
you know 0.1 right if the first check-in
is at 4 between 4 & 5 that column all of
a sudden jumps to 1 which is on the top
of a you know where the title is so as
more data comes in the distribution
moves away from the prior and then it
starts to match what the data is saying
so yeah
in this case about 30 to 100 check-ins
will override the prior and I think
that's about right yeah in the back
yes
yeah so that's a very good point by
breaking up the weekday into 168
different buckets in different hours we
lose a lot of information one
information that you know obviously we
use is like we're in the hour that
checking occurred totally lost and
another is the fact that you know this
time has structure and you know if
people are checking in at 4:00 4:00 a.m.
and 5:00 a.m. there probably will be
checking in 3:00 a.m. I don't know there
if someone's checking in at one pocket
they might be more likely to check in to
the next quarter and I haven't I've
thought about some ways to make use of
that and it was smoothing across buckets
and things like that but haven't haven't
really done it yeah I really need it yet
but that's definitely something to keep
in mind and something to think about I
think all the different ways to do that
are a little bit out of scope but it's a
good question I agree with you yeah
I'm sorry I don't think I got that
entirely yeah
so we're looking for outliers that that
are going to be very different from this
distribution yeah
right
so so yeah so one thing we could do is
you know I think what you're saying is
you know maybe we want to build a
mixture model they're just different
types of venues like these are in this
category here might be you know bars in
general and so this is like where all
the bars are open and so if I'm a new
bar maybe I want to go in there and then
over here is like you know 24-hour
diners and over here is like workplaces
and then as a venue come in maybe we
know the category already or maybe as
some data starts trickling in it becomes
clear well it's a it's a clear outlier
in this mixture so and it definitely
seems like it fits in here so I'll put
it in here and yeah so if you did it
that way I think it would we converge to
the right answer a lot closer or a lot a
lot quicker so you're right about that
haven't needed to do it just because
generally the only problems new venues
and after a while we have enough data
but yeah if we were serious about doing
that that that would help
he's so great
so okay so the question is we're talking
about names that are being classified
into different ethnicities I'm kind of
I'm gonna make asked if this is right so
if you have data like this where each
row is a different name and each column
is a different ethnicity and you have
these you have these counts but and your
question is how do we divide up the oat
Oken of the name yeah I mean yeah so I I
don't know if this is necessarily the
most appropriate model you might you
might want to do you might want to do
analysis I'm like well actually no you
might want to look at you know for each
token let's say each row is a token you
know you might want to give each token
percentages like a sign of a multinomial
for each for each possible ethnicity now
when you have a bunch of tokens you can
kind of come up with a system for
combining
naivebayes or something like that I
think but what was your original
question in terms of dealing with
okay what do you talk to me afterwards
I'll get into more detail
yes yeah yeah a little bit of an
afterthought I've met interesting ideas
this is
it's a multinomial distribution order
works
sorry
yeah
right right listen so you're looking at
right so I it's the question about the
color game works and that's what I want
to get into like the whole model here
but you know so each document is
considered a mixture of topics and each
topic is a mixture of works
right
yes so each each topic is a mixture over
words
so for example if you think of it the
topic we can think of like words of art
and then each document is a mixture of
topics so some documents are to be all
that one topic and then some are to be a
few topics but you want a very small
number of topics that's why you keep
that yes
this is the last slide Oh which one are
you talking about
this one yeah
I'm sorry can you say that again
okay this this graph this graph
represents nearish latency between this
is a 168 dimensional during a
distribution and each value of alpha is
represented by the bar
how does this what oh right well I mean
popularity of a venue at a given time is
an input to our recommendation engine
it's not it's not a very big one place
is new we want to be able good guess
yeah
do I see application to prediction can
you give me a little more
yeah
right
um so I mean you're you're talking about
like I think they're talking about like
uh you know classification problem
machine learning and then but I don't
think that the just applying one darish
lay over every row is very good at
classifying the rows but if you were to
do something more complicated like build
a mixture model and then for each row
figure out which which mixture it goes
into that could be something that's a
that produces some good classifications
any trouble and then it would be good
because each or each row like if it
doesn't have enough data you'd know that
you know we don't know which cluster
it's in yet and then as the data rolls
in it becomes more obvious which
question them to put
if we just take the average doesn't look
like this it's like yes so if we take
the average 168 vector for four square
venues we took them and we ever egde
them all together what does it look like
well the distribution looks a lot like
this but the weight is I mean we don't
get away from that we just get we just
get a distribution so so yes if you had
an idea of what weight you wanted and
you just want to click an average and
crunch it you could do that all right I
think I think we're good there any other
questions who come to me after but thank
you very much